apparently Sony's Morbius will be a very
specific kind of vampire the sexy kind
there's actually actor Jared Leto's
shared what appears to be a set photo
from the forthcoming flick to his
Instagram recently and if you can look
past the rippling torso and tight abs
you may find there's more going on than
meets the eye
the actor has been all about teasing
Morbius via social media on April 4th
2019 he even posted a short video of
himself in character standing on a busy
city streets while throngs of passers-by
rush around him in a blur
Leto claimed to have posted the set
photo in honor of the anniversary of
this is war the third album by his rock
band 30 Seconds to Mars but it's
obviously meant to be a bit of a Morbius
tease as well see that dark smear of
blood at the corner of letõs mouth so to
state the obvious Jared Leto is a
good-looking man and he's obviously
following in the time-honored tradition
of superhero movie stars like Thor's
Chris Hemsworth by getting into
incredible shapers role as dr. Michael
Morbius the biochemist who has
traditionally been the staunch opponent
of your friendly neighborhood spider-man
but there are a couple of possible clues
in the photo that warrants a closer look
first letter was sporting a distinctive
Casio digital wristwatch the kind that
was popular in the 80s and 90s this
could be a clue about the time period
Morbius will be set in so far director
daniel espinosa hasn't revealed any real
plot details or the film's period
setting but the watch's placement here
certainly invites speculation of course
it could just be indicative of letõs
taste and timepieces difficult to say
more importantly either Leto has
suddenly sprouted a whole bunch of moles
on his face or he's covered in those
tracking dots used in motion capture
performances note that in his vampire
form Morbius --is well frankly he's
hideous in the comics rather than
practical makeup
it appears that special effects house
envisage will be using CGI to create the
living vampires ghastly look and yes
that's the same house that provided the
effects for Sony's venom we
this could be viewed as a positive or a
negative depending on how you feel about
Venom's special effects while plenty of
bands were perfectly satisfied with the
title character's appearance others felt
that the CGI left a lot to be desired
some moviegoers even thought the effects
looked dated
of course venom and Morbius are two
characters with completely different
looks and even if envisage fell short
and rendering the former they could
still totally crush it when it comes to
Morbius after all the special effects
house did awesome work for Espinoza on
his film life and on last year's
underrated nazi zombie thriller overlord
plus it's worth noting that venom made
eight hundred and fifty five million
dollars worldwide which may encourage
Sony to pony up a bit more cash for
Morbius special effects budget and any
rate let OHS excitement over the
upcoming film is positively contagious
and we're psyched to see what spin he
puts on the material following venom
Morbius will be the second installment
in the Sony universe of Marvel
characters which the studio is building
because it still holds the rights to a
whole bunch of characters associated
with spider-man the Sony and Marvel deal
won't last forever and Sony's leverage
with Marvel could depend on how well its
Sony universe of Marvel offerings do at
the box office as previously noted venom
did just fine we'll see just how big a
bargaining chip Morbius represents when
it hits the big screen on July 31st 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more exclusive looper
videos about Morbius spider-man and the
Sony universe of Marvel characters are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]